What is everyone think? Is 2 the right answer here? Well,
let's look at the choices. First note, that both 2 and 4 are legitimate answers.
2 is legitimate because we can think of the transformation from
A to B as a reflection around the vertical axis. And so
if we think of the transformation from C to D, again as a reflection of
the vertical axis, we'll get 2. 4 is also a correct answer, because we
can think of the transformation from A to B as a rotation of 180 degrees, and
if we rotate C by 180 degrees we'll get 4. However, if we look at our
weights again, we gave reflection a higher weight than we gave rotation. And
therefore, David is right, 2 indeed is the correct answer.